welcome to thick boy fight news let's
dive in
two major fights were reported in the
bantamweight division for ufc 280 in abu
dhabi on october 22nd the more shocking
of the two was pyotr yan rashan o'malley
espn mma tweeted
at sugashan mma announced during an
interview with atrial r clark 25 that he
will fight at pyoter yawn ufc next at
ufc 280 in abu dhabi
twitter in twitter fashion was in utter
disbelief shaheen al-shadi of
mmafighting.com tweeted
talk about a step up good lord can't
accuse this man of ducking anyone
anymore this is wild matchmaking
welterweight balla muhammad who fights
sean brady on ufc 280 tweeted simply wow
banger mortal kombat's luke thomas
expressed that sean o'malley is
silencing his detractors with this one
can't say o'malley is running from a big
test whatever you thought of the munoz
result it's out of the frying pan and
into the fire with this
bar stool sports robbie fox chimed in
holy [ __ ] what a step up for o'malley
the second bantamweight fight announced
was that for a title espn mma also broke
the news on twitter that al aljamain
sterling will defend his belt against tj
dillashaw on the megacard.ufc 280 in abu
dhabi
mma junkie had reported earlier that
sterling dillashaw was originally being
targeted for ufc 279 on september 10th
but that the offer had been rescinded
for the nate diaz hamza chemaya bout now
reported to be taking place on that date
if the reported bantamweight super
fights become finalized they will join
the lightweight title fight between
charles oliveira and islam makachev on a
star-studded main card for ufc 280.
talk of welterweight champion kamaru
usman fighting at light heavyweight has
been swirling since he posted an
instagram facing off with yon wakovic at
ufc 276. usman has stated in the past he
will not pursue a second belt at
middleweight due to his friendship with
israel adesania number 5 ranked
lightweight anthony smith joined michael
bisping on the believe you me podcast to
question usman at 205 why why because he
wants to be a double champ and he won't
fight israel otasania they won't fight
each other which is weird to me a little
bit i know there's some national pride
that's some of it it's a nigeria thing
but it's not like they train together i
don't get the vibe that they're really
good friends and hang out smith
continued it's like back in the day when
brazilians didn't want to fight each
other i think we're past some of that so
i don't see the issue here i think 170
is a hell of a jump i'm trying to figure
out how to say something without
trashing him i like usman a lot but
that's a big jump
brendan schaub also questioned usman's
ability to jump up two weight classes on
the most recent episode of the shob show
kamar usman says after the leon edwards
edwards fight william wins i saw this i
don't get it he's so small yeah jumping
two divisions right so five yeah
but that's what he wants
i i j like him versus yuri it's like
what his lower body is what's not light
heavyweight his lower body is
you know lightweight 155.
boxing superstar ryan garcia is already
looking forward to his next fight after
knocking out javier fortuna in the sixth
round last saturday at crypto.com arena
tuesday afternoon garcia sent out a
flirty of tweets towards jervante davis
the first of which was accompanied by a
video of garcia's finishing left hook on
fortuna
garcia followed up with another tweet
claiming that tank davis is afraid to
step into the ring with him i feel like
imma have to go full ali vibes when he
had to chase down sunny liston to make
him fight this man is terrified deep
down and i'm talking about you at
gervante i know you see my tweets saying
nothing or something won't save you from
this whooping garcia tweeted again this
time suggesting a new national holiday
today is bugged the [ __ ] out of at
gervante day
july 19th new holiday he locked himself
in the bunker once he's seen the truth
i'm knocking you out no mercy
any potential fight between the two will
first require cooperation from their
respective promotions garcia is signed
with golden boy promotions and tied to
the zone streaming service while davis
is with mayweather promotions and
showtime boxing fans know too well
putting together these super fights are
easy to tweet about but harder to get
done
at ufc london media day paddy got the
chance to tell reporters including those
from the mac life how he really feels
about his opponent jordan levitt levitt
has been vocal since the fight was
announced that he plans to twerk after
beating pimplet which has since inspired
patty to come up with a celebration of
his own
where do you think he's what do you
think he's coming from with this is he
just trying to get in your head isn't he
trying to get him being a little weirdo
like he is but no one can outweird me
i'm weirder than anyone
is there a chance you twerk over him if
he gets i'm gonna teabag him lad i'm on
a tea bag i'm like that's modern warfare
too
for the uh uninitiated at home what is
tea bag i want to squat as close to his
head as i possibly can without the ref
shot one at me okay just squat up and
down like i'm on modern warfare 2 lad
thank you for clarifying that um how do
you see the fight itself actually going
he was trying to say it's going to be a
bit of a grappler versus grappler what
do you see no it's not i'm going to come
out i'm going to take his head off
i'm not i'm i'm not going to be shooting
no takedowns i'm coming to stand with
him to take his head
off i'm coming to take his chin on with
me
he can't throw a punch to save his life
he really can't lie he comes to fights
not he doesn't come into fights to win
he comes into fight not to lose
what i mean try and take me down sit on
top of me and sniff me balls for three
rounds that's not gonna work
when asked about levitt's earlier
comments that he expects a grappling
match paddy vehemently disagreed
draftking sportsbook put out their
opening ons for the nate diaz hamza
chemaya fight the mayav opened up as a
huge betting favor over diaz at minus
1150
those odds didn't seem to deter jake
paul who tweeted that he'll be putting
his money in the other direction
better believe i'm putting my money on
nate diaz to win vs fake khabib
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
[Music]
you